nach hause warte warte hier sind
pinguine so meine lieben freunde ich
bekämpfe jetzt meine angst gegenüber den
pinguinen weil die haben mich in der
reihenfolge in ein loch ein geschubst wo
ich dann getötet wurde
für sportler also die brennen weihnacht
droht jetzt allerdings mehr jetzt könnte
ich habe mein kopf kommt zu einem
weiteren teil minecraft hier und da bin
ich nicht alleine sondern mit dem luca
der sich alle drei tage pausiert er
erwähnte direkt ja genau
hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück mit der p midcap in
der stadt drin was ist eigentlich eine
aufgabe der stadt kef ich bin der
waffenmeister ach ja du hast du diese
coole aufgabe ich bin eine höhere essens
fritze wo bist du denn ich bin gerade
bei den amadeus in der roten ebene bei
uns wenn du auf mein haus zu läuft vom
stadtkern wie sich noch was sind wieso
ist ja noch bisschen was von diesem
scheiß ich könnte jetzt ein play-off du
hast auch ein bisschen ahnung so van
heek widme ich bin ja so einer der sich
erst an den hausbau setzen möchte er
kannst du mir deine gute rüstung
empfehlen jetzt eventuell nicht die
scale rüstung weil ich habe jetzt nichts
an so marco di carli sense ist eine von
der stadt ja ich kann gleich eben zurück
komme ich doch eben steuerbürger angeben
so nicht die skills und habt ihr
komplettes geld bis zum gerade an
ja weil ich habe halt nicht so viele
sachen ich war halt noch nicht so los
ich habe auch erst 13 folgen glaube ich
hero oder franz ausgestorben wie ich ne
nein ich bin guck doch mal ob du bist
okay du bist viermal ich bin ja okay gut
den als fünfmal
jedoch ist sechs mal sechs mal keine
angeschrieben aber ich hab alles drum
internet grimaud bauen was denn ein riff
tritt weil bei mir ich hatte das portal
hier stehen und jetzt immer wenn die
kamera auf aufgefressen
aja wegen dem doofen ender mails und so
ihr haus gefesselt ja ich habe schon ein
paar namens getötet und ein paar von
diesen riffs weg gemacht weil mich das
so aufgeregt hat das team und ich mal
mit erde zu aber ich baue auch das ding
ist ein gmbh das hab ich auch immer
wieder die festen mein hobby blog anteil
hat und ja ich werde voll dankbar wenn
du das werk bauen würde das alter wie
gesagt also es liegt eigentlich nicht in
meinem den griff ja deswegen wäre mir
natürlich älter wäre schon cool ja bin
dabei eine weitere premiere gebaut keine
ahnung hat wer hilft habe ich nicht das
gefühl und ich wollte glaube ich ganz
level fahren weil ich habe mir gerade
hier von so ein bisschen was ist das
filmmaterial das ist marburg opels toni
macht dann zum apple store und den mache
ich mir dann als boden anstatt diesen
komischen holz was ich hatte obwohl ich
weiß nicht das holz auch ganz gut aber
das ihm begeistert und keller oder
irgendwas bleibt auf jeden fall so ein
paar tolle ideen für meine häuser ein
was sie nicht fragen wollte hast du
zufällig bücher oder die du einfach so
nicht brauchst oder ich habe gekämpft
und ich wollte mir noch so einen schönen
botanischen garten anlegen wo ich das
dann an land weil wo kriegt man denn
bücher heraus den festungen da sind
bestimmt irgendwo bücherregal oder dies
behindert ein fachkräften
ja aber wie viel wie gesagt ich brauche
14 book selbst also dass ihre
bücherregale wofür
ja weil das ding ist man kann manche
verzauberungen nur drauf machen man
mindestens zwölf oder vierzehn
bücherregale und eventuell zusammen sein
ding machen dann kümmern wir uns ja
genau ich wollte das gleich für die
stadt machen aber ich habe nur vier
bücherregale und ich will jetzt einfach
nicht kräften wir das würde zu lange
dauern und ich glaube irgendwo hier muss
es doch welche geben ohne witz ohne
schwert in einen dungeon mit eigenem
verkackt ja ich habe vielleicht auch
meine dungeon tor machen noch gerne
machen ja gut dann wollen wir sie danach
treffen weil wir nehmen jetzt zwei
frettchen auf solche mannschaften in der
nähe ist ein geburt ich hab eigentlich
in jedem ort in der nähe gelegt ja ich
komme jetzt mal einen namen
das problem ist nur hast du electric
lizenzen oder elektriker centers schenke
ich dir die magischen lizenzen
dann können wir nämlich fliege
zauberstäbe machen weil ein teil der
magischen essenzen also eine magische
essent sind acht verschiedene essenzen
und ich habe zehn magische center auch
kein elektriker lou sanson bei ab ich
hab im blut bekämpft bei mir ist es
bisher also ich war noch ein gar keinem
dungeon drin hast du noch nichts getötet
habe ich noch in cannes dungeons oder
natürlich von mir einfach ich habe so
eine komplette kiste mit ausrüstung ja
das will ich auf jeden fall die sache
ist halt nur dass alle das bei mir daran
liegt dass ich halt durch lange
in handy gehandicapt war wegen meinem pc
und ja das war zehnmal das weiß ich ja
nicht nur also ich hab das schon letzten
folge erzählt aber jetzt mal verkauft
und dann die dies mitbekommen haben ich
habe mir einen neuen pc zugelegt und ich
wollte dann einfach mal so schlug ich
bin also das ist ja logisch man erstellt
bevor man die ganzen sachen auf dem
neuen pc draufpackt macht man
systemabbild vom alten pc und hat dann
halt wieder hoch also macht dann wieder
da drauf da dachte ich mir dann auch so
schön machte das mal mensch in form von
sicherheit und seite
ja klar dann allerdings nicht weil
lieber freund wenn das ganze system
abbild natürlich beschädigt ist das ist
dann natürlich nicht so schön raster
schön fand ich auf jeden fall nicht
sogar ein systemabbild gemacht und
deshalb einstimmig ja ich konnte es doch
nicht davon wieder herstellen oder man
alle daten weg weiß was weißt du was da
drin war
praktiker dateien und praktikums et
cetera eine bewerbungs datei für eine
universität meine facharbeit allesamt
referate alle youtube dateien intro auto
alles was ist natürlich alle möglichen
verträge von von irgendwelchen
netzwerken
alles alles wegwerfen oder schlimmsten
die ganze pornos sammlung von uns beiden
ohne witz das ist das schlimmste was ich
will ich so viel aber wir den perfekten
schnitt mit dem zentrieren man doch
einfach durch den mit dem mit dem ja nie
aber auch mit mit dem perfekten bumsen
dann halt einfach ne es ist halt einfach
weg also bei mir wie das rausgeschnitten
das fand ich nicht so durfte wie das und
wie das so schön als ob jetzt hast du
wirklich rausgeschnitten
natürlich ist noch drin auch das
hauptaugenmerk auf die auf die
vorbereitungen gesetz nicht auf den boom
boom akt auf die ach so auf dem weg ich
komme zu dir du hast du recht bei aller
würde nicht schlagen ja noch kein
verzauberung glaub mir fehlen die level
und mir fehlen ich will verzaubern ich
habe mich auf meine zauberstäbe dass das
seelen gebunden ist wenn ich sterbe ich
dass viele kinder im inventar das wie
auch alles verzaubern
das kostet einfach 12 level aber dazu
gleich links gut
ihr könnt ihr steckt
kannst du mir dann eben die rüstung
geben das wäre ich total niedlich benimm
dich nur brocken fans hat mir gesagt ich
darf mir jetzt erstmal bei denen holen
was ich will weil die mir jetzt okubo
sondern nicht zurückgegeben haben wir
ganz klar sagen an die kiste das zeugt
ja aber vielleicht auch bei brockens
natürlich auch noch bessere sache wenn
die kiste die würde ich sowieso spenden
auch außer die ganz unterzeile kannst du
überall rüstung nehmen was verzauberte
was du haben willst india schuhe ja
durch ich lass mich mal ganz kurz
ausnahme die nicht mit ankara erkennt
weil mich dass du wieder an wie du hast
noch mal neun im triple play liegt die
sache nahm hinterher du ich kümmere mich
übrigens auch um straßengestaltung und
umwelt das ist fantastisch jetzt
neuerdings hat irgendwas ich an deiner
stelle empfehlen würde ist dass du
mystical sieht bei allen sammelst das
sind nämlich du kennst bestimmt die
büsche die du so abbaut und da kommt
dann entweder ein herz und ein pfeil und
so rausnehmen und eure jahr ist ihr kiez
ist auf gras platz hier ist sonst du
diese büsche und da könntest du so ein
feld für die stadt machen wie man sich
direkt vor regieren kann
wenn es mal brenzlig wird ja moment ich
versuche irgendwie meine spiele in so
eine coole zwischenwand bauen aber das
gelingt mir nicht so wo findet man gut
bücherregale hast du eine ahnung wie
kann ich das machen die könnte so eine
bahn bauen alter borchen die idee
bücherregale du ich glaube ich habe ein
typischer ich glaube ich habe bücher ich
habe hier fünf jahren allein ich brauche
noch über 16 bücher gleiche geben alle
haben bitte ich hab auch 26 27 schüler
kennen kann ich auch noch geben
yeah ich behalte mir mal die hälfte
davon
damit mir einfach machen kann soll hier
da ich hab was heißt direkt im hof in
hast du leder
wieder war es auch kein problem ich habe
ich wollte mir gestern unserem bett
backpack machen als mitglieder
aufgenommen habe ach so und das ding ich
hab doch becks ehrlich ich hab hier bloß
sind wie doppelte kisten auf eine weisse
spiele ich mir so tischer machen kann
also cool edition nicht so einen
komischen also ich kann mir auf jeden
fall noch ein rotes backpack schenken
ich hab hier noch 1 oder können wir auch
in magic backpack habe ich wollte noch
mal als backpacker und großes rennen zu
gehen ja schon ich habe mich nicht
zurück kräften habe ich noch irgendwas
einer serie darstellt kann man einfach
ein schild tragen ja wenn du normales
schweren dass allein das wort ist beides
gemischt was bringt einem friseur ex
alter wer baute mitte unter wasser bäume
ab man die habe ich genug wird bei einem
brand fast genau wie hier guck mal die
feier habe ich alle gute toben was sind
boots & living metal boots am probieren
ach so ich habe ja noch wirst du mir auf
den ständern hier falls gucken will hier
eine waffensteuer gemacht damit werde
ich hier ist noch ein rucksack aber
dienstmann bisschen schneller
ja wir wissen wir schon alles so ich
mache mir dann wäre ein paar bücherregal
ich hoffe das reicht so aus wollen wir
ganz kurz schlafen gehen können wir
machen ja aber ja ich schreibe ja ich
bin recht schnell entkräften
kev geht auch sekunde
ok ich liege ja ich hab hier rein noch
gar nicht doch jetzt liege ich drin
liege hätt de vito russo reingehen a b c
d e f g h i j k l m n o p q
klappt man oh baby soll die reihe und da
brauchen
okay gut ich habe dir ich komme bei dir
also ich selber noch papier 62 papier
habe ach so ich geb dir jetzt auch
gleich eine scroll of skate night magic
mirror
das bringt magic mirror den darfst du
haben auch ein spezielles geschenk von
mir wenn du in der höhle bis rechtsklick
machst wirst an die oberfläche
teleportiert da sind so sachen die
einfach irgendwann immer werden
dann hält er ziehe mich unendlich
ziemlich mutig war so viel fehlt nicht
mehr wir sollten jetzt aber denkt der
attacke machen
ich habe jetzt zehn bücher den beiden
fehlen noch vier stück ich habe noch
zwei blocks das heißt wir feld eins plus
neun auf zehn bücher das sollte denke
ich zu machen seien zehn bücher kaufen
temporary dolls special tarif welt auf
keinen fall mitnehmen das ist das was
ich hier bei mir habe und deswegen aber
die probleme ähnlich das nicht okay
fragt sich jetzt denn das wort mitnehmen
weiß ich gar nicht womit dann mal los
ja ich guck mal gerade ganz klar
diamond2 enders wollten der feier drei
verzaubert so ich geh einfach in
richtung was man sieht ja gar nicht
norden osten kann ich mir auch etwas
verzaubern und du kannst du den tisch so
wie du willst
alles kein thema ach so ich gehe
richtung friedhof da vorne ist eine
festung dies wichtig da also die kriegst
du auf jeden fall zu gesicht frage wo
geht es in richtung friedhof davon dass
wir die beiden festungen okay was wir zu
sagen was mit nehme ich mir auf jeden
fall essen für uns beide mit ja
schöne krippen musste sein na ja klar
und dann sitze ich habe alles mit aber
erzeugt dabei eine also hatte ich bin
einfach nur auf sein leben mit ok was
das tue ich jetzt daran weil hier vorne
ich glaube irgendwo muss es doch im raum
gehen wo bücherregale sind muss es
den nehme ich mal wenn das nicht geht
achtet der häuser nirgendwo
da muss dann jemand gedacht habe ohne
bücherregal wieder so leer aus heißt das
dass wir so denken die map bauer einmal
die bauern über ein bücherregal in magic
marker nicht nur in höhlen benutzen
ich probiere das mal ich bin jetzt hier
in einem haus und nutzte das und werde
zum und werdet zum ausgang wenn du in
einem haus bist wirst du zum ausgang
hingedeutet
also kann ich das doch nicht nehmen dann
schon wenn ich auf einmal schlecht dran
bin mir klar
und das hat nur etwas eigentlichen
therapie star keine ahnung das weiß ich
nicht die butter noch da lassen
den habe ich den beirat bei mir noch
gefunden was euch verzaubern lieber
bevor ich damit hingehe ich verzaubert
manager ich habe fünf lehrer gefunden
kämpft euch meine deine giants wortes
verzaubert oder einfach oder gibt es
noch viel bessere schwerter ich weiß
dann mit schwertern kenne ich mich
ehrlich gesagt dann wieder doch nicht so
aus das ist dann das ding jetzt weiß ich
nicht und volker ist klar dass ich da
drauf verzaubern sharpless my way of a
prospectus häufig gemacht habe auch nur
drei ich habe auch noch schaffen h3 habe
ich nur verzaubert was war das für ein
zungenbrecher schafften es drei hamm az
also wurde offenbar schon alles
geplündert außer das leder wir haben ja
ich hab jetzt schon 20 lehrer gesammelt
in der höhle in dem ganzen hier nicht
und ich kann ihn nicht werten dieses
dungeon so dreckig schlecht gelüftet
jeder zweiten kiste hab ich ja noch was
drin
0 24 0 müsste folge vorbei jobs ghana
respekt ja du ich noch 18
also zwei bücherregale konnte ich wie
gesagt schon luton ich hoffe es geht
doch dann hinauf mit auf den weg ich
konnte dir hast du blöcke dabei was
topco blöcke dabei hast warte ich mir
hier hab ich hab alle achsen so dabei
habe
ich lade sechs bücherregal auf einmal
gefunden alle ab unabhängig genug jetzt
schon fertig na gut ich will aber noch
ein bisschen was machen das jetzt ganz
ehrlich so ein up griff und dungeon das
schon manchmal geleitet wurde
wer hier vorne ja nicht oder du wirst
noch daheim ich bin doch schon bei dir
hier die kids auch schon leer ist hier
schon hier ist alles der betrieb muss
unten einfach kommen hier einfach hin zu
mir du bist leider sieht man es hier
nicht so wie minimap man sieht
eigentlich auf der karte das schade
finde ich ja ich habe meinem haus
übrigens vollkommen hiermit hin
sobald sich zwecks exakt und genau da
wollte ich den boss hier unten die
schildkröte habe ich schon alleine
genommen
wir zeigen wir eine seite rein buddeln
hier irgendwann vorsichtig natürlich ist
kann im redstone schaltung ich lasse mir
von ex-kanzler apache neuen was tasten
sollen 50 4
es ist dunkel ach so aber da hab ich
leuchte aus gut müssen wir einen weg
gefolgt mir einfach so wenn du willst
kannst hier natürlich auf eine vielfalt
und bücherregalen erwartet nämlich alle
mit gut bekommen hast du hier war
offenbar auch schon jemand aber haben
sie auch den geheimen raum hier bekommen
sie ziemlich geheim räume ja ja ja die
habe ich auch schon gesehen dass export
und bei mir standen wir hier kugel geht
weder durchlaufen das einfach mal dass
wir so ein bisschen noch klar wir haben
jetzt noch zwei minuten denkt da können
wir jetzt noch schnell ja mal
durchlaufen zitiert eine ebene höher
bist du wo jetzt kommt der dunkelsten
durchgelaufen
wo bist du ja hier ist noch nie sind
keine fackeln das heißt hier war keiner
ich habe mich jetzt mal eben hoch ich
bin noch eine etage über dem einnahmen
nicht ja doch was macht rom
ja ich gehe hier ganz hoch jetzt leben
ich möchte der king auf der welt sein da
auch hier haben jedoch diese ihr habt
ihr doch die wahl veranstaltet oder
denn ja aber hier waren schon welche
sind überall so erich weiß deswegen ich
schaue nur nach dem bereich wo die halt
noch nicht wann
und da unten war nicht ausgeleuchtete
passage schalter waren jedoch nicht wenn
wir zurückgehen das können wir noch
schnell in dieser folge vielleicht
schaffen wir das noch denn jetzt ist
zurück zurück zurück wo ist das loch
hier die kinder kommen hat er hier vorne
ist nicht ausgeleuchtet hier waren nicht
drin
hier war ich schon
sie habe ich schon genug hier noch ins
nächste station suchen
das hier ist schon gespannt
noch ein paar junge bäume mit war das
journal holzschild nirgendwohin gebohrt
wurde sinnvoll ist und jetzt immer alles
klar nach hause
warte warte hier sind pinguine so meine
lieben freunde ich bekämpfe jetzt meine
angst gegenüber den pinguinen weil die
haben mich in der reihenfolge in ein
loch ein geschoss wo ich dann getötet
wurde
für sportler also die brennen was not
tut ja jetzt können allerdings mehr
jetzt könnte ich habe im kopf
ich hoffe den kopien kopf so gefällt mir
das roma hat kann ich mir den aufsätzen
haben würde ich sagen ich natürlich die
regel
ich töte die einfach direkt die gucken
mich an und ist nicht mehr so schnell
die sterben einfach diese komische leute
ich wieder hier sind noch eine kugel
hole ein bisschen lederjacken wir
machtlos wie ich hab schon 20 leben
blogger leder mehr leute wir sehen uns
in der nächsten folge einfluss zusammen
hier lest ihr hier hey wir sagen ja wir
beim nächsten mal wieder wenn es euch
gefallen hat was dürfen die machen ein
bäumchen nach oben geben und dann aber
ich helfe dir eben noch ihr körper
plündern gleich dann will ich dann
bleibt keine leute macht es klatsch das
zunächst mal